thank you good to be here back up in
Berkeley it's a nice place um so yes
Stiles workshop of new classical methods
into student our society trouble can't
figure exactly what that meant but I
decided that the closest topic I could
give was one of my favorite sort of
things to be evangelized about maybe is
is is that is the connections between
discrete mathematics and continuous
mathematics and really that they're not
as far apart as we sort of traditionally
make them to be you know so you're most
of us here are time working at discrete
mathematics or maybe my called planetary
mathematics quantitative mathematics
sweet objects planet objects and what
bounds explicit bounds and that's one
side of analysis where something's got
hard analysis and then on the other side
of analysis we have the opposite occur
or where you were continuous objects or
infantry objects infinite uncountable
spaces like that
and you're often only gave our
qualitative it over selves so you don't
care about bounds just coming exists or
some converges but you don't specify
rates or anything and you've got some
different people working in one world
and in the other but there's really a
lot of connections between the two so
certainly there's a bit analogies you
know so for example in the continuous
world you have reminding manifolds for
example so a continuous object and there
are super metric inequalities and Qi
gonna call inequalities and so forth and
of course that in the discrete world we
now have always nice analogue so please
money geometry type was outs for for
various types of graphs and so forth so
this is the certain laws lots of
analogies between discrete mathematics
and continuous mathematics but the
connection is stronger than just analogy
that there are really rigorous
bridges that you pass between discrete
objects and continuous objects and in
particular allow you to use results from
continuous mathematics as a black box to
prove results in discrete mathematics so
there's lots of examples of this that
you probably already know of so for
example in the discrete
or you might carry off my grass by dense
grass a and you want to prove various
theorems about finite dense grass and
nowadays we have the square tool graph
limits which takes a sequence of fun
dense graphs and produces out of it I
take the continuous object hold a graph
on okay which is basically a measurable
function on the you know square and you
can and you can then use tools from
continuous continuous mathematics
example you can you can you can hit
graph on some major theory tools like a
little bit differentiation theorem for
instance and you can use that to start
to prove things of things back up about
Planet X classic example probably
testing while trying to remove all Emma
we could have to learn these little
things another famous example you might
be interested in dense substance of the
integers okay example you want one
approvers they're very Sturm that or
subsidy integers positive density
contains arbitrarily long progressions
and in the 70s Furstenberg introduced
the correspondence principle
which connected then subset of the
integers to measure preserving systems
like your positive measure subsets of
measurable slippin systems so a measure
preserving system is a probability space
with it with a shift on it some sort of
measurement of map which preserves a
measure and then once you have this set
up you can hit you can hit this with the
techniques of a gothic theory I'm not so
spectral theory and a couple other
continuous towards mathematics actively
vergata clear for instance and so he
famously gave the second proof of
szemeredi's theorem using the Gothic
lyric methods see more examples you
might be interested in what are the
examples okay so you might be interested
in discrete metric spaces example Cayley
grass or something and we have this tool
to convert if you have a to take limits
of discrete metric spaces that produce
continuous metric spaces out of them
visibly the twelve grow more house off
limits
and then you can use lots of tools from
a continuous metric geometry to then you
know like software spaces in whatever -
to analyze just the unrolling discrete
spaces in particularly the continuous
limits may have various group symmetries
that only hold in some approximate or
asymptotic sense in the discrete world
okay you might be interested in
polynomials of bounded degree for some
discrete problem over some field or
maybe varieties how do varieties or find
a complexity comes the same almost same
thing for tea time nice we looked at
Hanceville okay I'll find a complexity
so it's just a variety set up by a
bounded number or palm is about a degree
and you want to to to to ask
quantitative questions about these
things like for example if you give I
give you about a number of polynomials
cutting out some set some object variety
they may have very minimal components
how many components do you get I can
bound that the the novel components in
terms of the degrees of polynomials that
you haven't so forth
and there's a way to take limits where
you just and in the limit the
qualitative analogue it's just well it's
just polynomials and varieties with no
bound one degree
and okay so about time I talk about with
this sort of limit here that the
cheapest in do is take natural product
and the point is that you can you can
use tours so over here you can you can
you can use the tools off this classical
algebraic geometry the ultimate Coventry
is is a noise is classically presented
is qualitative it tells you for example
a basic without is that is that every
algebraic set can be decomposed into a
finite number of areas welcome object
varieties but it doesn't give you about
it just is there's a finite number but
once you have that fact and if you just
use the outer appearances at all you can
get as a very quick corollary that
automatically there is a boundless of a
compactness theorem this is in fact once
you know as a black box that every
algebraic set can be equal in finance
many irreducible sub varieties you can
conclude that in fact any algebraic set
of complexity most M I mean it can be
defined by you know and was employed
with degree M or something can be
decomposed into a final number of arise
and the number of varieties banner by
only by constant appending running on em
and you can actually get up a free and
so there's there's lots of qualitative
results about object commentary are
automatically give you quantitative
analogues basically because sometimes
our drug companies close on outer
products okay and then a another example
I think one of time to talk about for
okay recently in additive color choice
we study a lot of boxing gloves these
are sort of sets a in some real group
actual group we just a finite but such
that the product set is this is small a
tour aids is funded by constant times a
thank you Dad technically this isn't
quite the definition of approximately
this is a definite set of small doubling
we actually usually impose a stronger
condition we want a to be symmetric to
the identity and we want a tour a to be
covered by K translates of a but
essentially it is this is the sort of
object that we care what so things
things like progressions geometric
progressions in a group or yeah or
finite groups and things like that and
again we have we have
a way of taking limits much like graph
limits actually which turn approximate
groups into neighborhoods of eternity in
a locally compact group
so this connection was first worked out
by faster using model theoretic methods
and then later Amanda Briard Ben green
and myself observed that yucky - you
just need other products again to
convert these discrete objects take a
sequence of discrete approximate groups
and in the limit create a continuous
object which would be so sort of the
picture to keep in mind that you might
have a discrete box here's a good
example in proximal group and then you
might make a denser and denser and
denser you have a sequence of box
inquiries get denser and denser and
denser and in the limit you should get a
continuous Square standing for discrete
discrete boxes like that get denser and
denser and there's a general way to do
this and the the point of doing this is
is that you there's the powerful tools
from the subject of topological group
theory that allow you to to study these
things in particular this is the
solution helpers fifth problem on how to
classify League group topologically
becomes very very useful and gives you
non-trivial it was Alex on approximately
factor even classifies them completely
so there's lots and lots of ways to take
limits of discrete objects to create
continuous ones and you can see that
there's also different ways to do it but
it turns out that there is a universal
way to take these limits and the
universal ways without your products
like we give you I could take all of
these like I could have just been
algebra wallabies there's a single tour
a single gadget an outer product which
what it does is that it takes a sequence
of spaces which in practice will be
discrete spaces and produces for you
automatically a canonical continuous
object which is you should think of as
the limit of use a good object and so
you don't need to learn all infinite you
don't yakiniku than all these different
different ways of taking limits you just
need to take Loomis one way and then you
can pass back and forth you can use them
to sweep head easily so this is what I
want to describe before I do that this
one is a little philosophy but limits
there are actually three notions of
limits mathematics and most people who
learn one
and which ones you'll earn depends on
whether you now and listen algebra is to
audition so it is a little bit
philosophy so what is the limit so the
even analyst the the notion limit that
you're most exposed to is that a
topological or metric limit so here what
happens is that you've some big space X
which is either topological space or
metric space and then inside this space
you have a movie a sequence sometimes an
app which is a fancier version of the
sequence okay yeah you have some
sequence in your in your in your set and
you have a notion of all the sequence
converging to a limit which in a metric
cases means that the distance is all go
to 0 or and the topological means that
all the neighbors of X trap your
sequence and so this is the standard
notion of limit that we're used to and
so like when when you write down say
your own house of limits photometric you
know the graph of the months usually
also put some sort metric first
macrosse1 suspensful you often use the
topological limit using say bacon
versions or we stock units of measures
so this is this is a limit which these
are the limits that the analysts are
most familiar with one thing to note
though is that you take these limits all
the elements all this the object you
want to deliver off have to lie in the
same space so you know you have to take
build a set of all graphs the face of
all dead subsets of images or something
and create us the space out of those
sometimes that's not so natural you know
it's just sometimes all these objects
really are living in different spaces
like like a graph on n vertices where
energy is changing and you could just
take a big Union and make them a big
space but that's optimally natural okay
by anyway this is these are the limits
that the analysts usually look if you're
now jube Reyes
you usually instead use categorical
limits direct and inverse limits
category theory so instead of so now
your objects might be set a set of
spaces is sequence of spaces and you
might have various Maps so you have a
sequence of spaces which all happen to
each other like this okay and then in
these might be groups for vector spaces
or riggings or whatever and very often
you can take a limit and create a big
space which is which which everybody
maps to or if the hours go the other way
okay you can open your Facebook data and
you can also have more fancy diagrams
than just do these chains okay so this
is directed in this limits a typical
example so if you take the cyclic group
of a prime this project specific group
of P squared you would P cubed and if
you just take the inverse limit and the
category rings you can you get the P
attics okay so this is these are
categorical limits algebra of them but
so you can take the limits of all kinds
of things but in order to be useful
limit you need lots and lots of maps
morphisms between objects before you or
the useful emerges so yeah so okay
Carlos lead morphisms topological Oh
metric members need convergence okay so
of course the famous issue you can take
limit of just any sequence okay yeah
first has all that in the same space and
second it has to converge before you can
expect a limit so ultra limits
okay so you can do if you use Outlook
folders and outer products you create
limits what this does for you is that
you can take now elements in any space
you can take elements X n which each
which lives in different space X n okay
and you can form a limit which won't lie
would won't lie in in any additional
spaces it will lie in the autre protocol
spaces which is a limiting space of all
these spaces but the the advantage of
ultra products is that you don't need
any more films as with the categorical
limits and you don't need any
convergence you can take any sequence in
any space and you create a little and
you know it sounds like it that's sort
of two could be true the
is this - its - to content free to do
anything but what it does very very
neatly is that it converts discrete to
continuous and that allows you to just
take or use all these continuous objects
out of the box okay so that's sort of
the philosophy all right so now I have
to tell you what an ultra talk to an
ultra products are okay these are these
are not scary objects these are these
are these avoiding schemes just on an
infinite set they're very discreet
things actually just in they just
haven't really on the natural numbers
okay so I need to define the notion of
along principle ultra folder alpha okay
and so and the space of non vult
reporters is called beta and /n but
never mind that
okay so a non-print for ultra folder
what it is formally by definition is
just a collection subsets
of the natural numbers and these subsets
should we call out the large subsets so
are tough so there's an uncountable
number of subsets of images you know the
even integers oranges whatever prime
numbers so forth so some of them we're
going to call alpha large and some of
them we're not not a collage and you
want to raise axioms and therefore
axioms that you want one of them is that
no finite sets up a large so okay only
big sets get to be large okay another
one is that into any intersection say a
few finite or to Apple large sets is
always a large okay okay so um all right
then the third axiom is that anything
big any set containing any subset of n
containing enough a large set this to
off a large okay so if you happen so
there's already alpha like you make it
bigger it's it's it's sort of a large
these two axioms basically tell you that
this F is a filter okay and then it's
the finer accent was use an ultra filter
and the first second term is non
principal so the axiom is that if you
take any subset of the integers then
either E or was compliment that's a
large so either the odd numbers are the
even numbers for example alpha wanted to
copy both because they were both in the
intersection would be alpha large but
know that only the empty sets that are
flush with no finite set is supposed to
just was vlkabok okay
so this is this is a non principal ultra
program and it's a mechanism for
defining an alpha large sets for large
sets if you like an auto filter is a
current account example arrows theorem
or infinite bode book or population so
once you have an out reporter and you
have an infinite number of voters
each one
which is given by a natural number
indexed by a natural number then you can
consider a voting system that if you
have a referendum if you want you want
to vote on something
if only the votes yes or no and by the
last axiom in particular images in
particular one of those either the yes
vote is a noble is to be alpha large and
then and then whichever answer is alpha
logic that wins the election okay so
that's a voting system and all these
axioms tell you that this voting system
is sort of rational you know that if
someone switches their vote from no to
yes then that increases the chances of
that the outcome is yes and so on and so
forth okay and and no finite sets alpha
dodge means there's no dictators and so
and you can you can generalize that
given any finite set of options you can
you can you can vote for any finite set
of options and exactly one of the
options will be an alpha large set so
it's it's basically a voting system with
no deficiencies all right that all the
the problem paradoxes of voting don't
occur and it's big it's because you you
have an infinite number of voters okay
so these things don't exist if you
replace this by planet Earth the only
existing influence them now at this
point you're supposed to give an example
of an afterthought numbers well true for
that but yeah this is there's a slight
problem is that these things can only be
constructed using as much choice
if you drop this no finite set thing
then you can make a dictator okay all
those sets that contain 17 is that's not
the large set that's not too potent but
it's not as a principal filter but those
aren't really we don't use that's a yeah
so if you have that if you have no
choice these are very easy to construct
you easy to understand my argument
basically it's a greedy algorithm just
yet but you have to run it an
uncountable length of time that you know
so no finite that is alpha large so any
Co finite set and he said which is
components finite is alpha large so
you've already got some sets you
declared alpha alpha large then maybe
you look at the even numbers the odd
numbers so I present neither of those
have to be alpha large but you gotta
pick one of them okay so you make a
choice okay so I say I choose the even
numbers to be alpha large and that gives
you a few more alpha large set so any
said that contains it contains the even
numbers is alpha large anything like you
move a find out about self elements even
up to a large but then there's say the
mop is 4/3 okay one more feature was the
0 more thing one of them has be a large
you make a choice you pick one you pull
that in and you just keep doing this an
uncountable number times ok
and you make it a huge number of choices
but eventually you create an out
reporter okay
so to build on these things that needs
the extra choice now that is a little
bit well if you're really sort of a
final just the best less sort of
unsatisfactory but well one nice thing
about this is a nicer sort of girdle
that says that any any statement which
is really finite rate and by financially
I mean that which is a feasible in piano
with no take so just in the next numbers
using just just addition of application
so all that you know like famous Last
Theorem or something any stable which it
which is which is feasible in piano
pathetic so basically anything finite
rate which is provable using the extra
choice or more precisely in the CFCF sep
3 acts eum's is provable without tax my
choice
so you can use ultra folders reusing
have some choice to prove something but
if what you're putting is finite rate
say that triangle removal mo or poor
because everybody still water you can
then then automatically it also you can
also prove it without choice okay so
from a logical perspective the fact that
use of choices is not an issue okay so
all right so these are long because per
object furred is this there's lots of
them is an uncountable number of these
algebra because you have to make the
uncommon own choices but what what one
does to take is limit is you just pick
one okay so you just you just choose one
non prints for ultra filter and it just
doesn't really matter which one I mean
they're not quite all isomorphic but it
but the definer properties ultra filters
are not so important for the purposes of
taking limits they're putting important
by other things but but you just pick
one alpha and just fix it for for the
rest of your mathematics and so
basically you just put you just pick a
voting protocol okay and so now you have
a way to to take votes you can sample of
any any you can ask a natural number the
natural numbers any question you like
and you will get an answer please pick
one and and this this this protocol is
always up has a good consistency
property since for these axioms
customers to tell you okay so now I want
to the algebra you can start taking
limits so as I said again any finite set
and if you have any sequence and a
finite set so you have a finite number
of Dolf of choices okay and every
natural number picks one with choices
then there's a unique limit basically
the outcome of your lecture so you
define the outer limit of all this of
this of the sequence in a finite space a
coloring if you wish to be the color or
vote or candidate which which which
requires an alpha large set of voters
okay this is always exactly one okay so
you have you have a notion you could at
any sequence in any secrets to give a
finite range has a limit okay there's no
wish of convergence
okay I mean if it does converge then it
is converged in the classical sense I
give it this X is eventually constant
then this this this limit will agree
with the classical note because of no
finite set is alpha logic but okay but
it generalizes the limit extends limits
just like the finite limit even all the
way up in go stretching the harmonic
group very similar actually okay so we
only finite set you can take any finite
so any sequence which is finitely valued
has a limit which is still in our space
okay now what if X is not instant what
if X is infinite let's suppose now you
have a sequence taking values in an
infinite space
well actually the way I'm going to think
about is that actually suppose every
element in your sequence just takes
values no different space and you know
monly xn takes values in the space of
grassland of n vertices so you get make
a sequence of graphs on n vertices wait
and gets bigger and bigger each xn is
finite but but the union is infinite now
in this case the limit yeah usually I
wouldn't when you have an infinite space
here there'll be no single xn which is
which is which comes up in alpha largest
assets at a time so so normally you
won't have a limit in this space but
what you waking this news that you can
still define a formal limit so you just
formally define to just be a
mathematical object and okay formally
actually if you want the precise
definition it finally the equivalence
classes of all other sequences which
agree with this sequence where you see
the two sequences are similar if xn is
equal to I and 1 alpha large set of n
okay this is the formal definition but
you shouldn't make too much attention to
it it is analogous to how you can track
the real numbers in classical analysis
out the rationals anyone both are wheels
on the standard ways to go the reals is
as the Cauchy completion metric
completion of the rationals you you can
define the wheels as equivalence classes
of Cauchy sequences rationals
okay where to bashing secrets are
equivalent if their differences go to
zero now you know this is a form
weighted final rules but no one actually
uses the definition I mean that's that's
there's only four foundational purposes
okay but you know the important thing is
that the rules exist okay I know that
they complete the completely the integer
so so never mind this okay the thing is
that you just formally defined a limit
okay and and two sequences have the same
limit if they agree eventually on
al-falaq set that if the voters agree
that they're the same
okay so this is just formally how you
defined a little bit and if the accents
live in all these spaces is the set of
all such limits for the ultra product
excess and it's called well this very
associations but I will call it product
of alpha and engines minik so facility a
limiting object okay so in the finite
case you just take the out the ultra
limit ultra products so I often find out
well particle finite said you will just
get back the same finite set but that's
the only thing that you can get if you
this is if X is finite if X is infinite
like the ultra product of a set itself
this is called the ultra power of X come
to power and it's strictly bigger than X
okay so if you have a constant sequence
then your limit is that is that constant
but you can have non constant sequences
which will take values in our solution
space so just like if you take limits of
Cauchy sequence of rational sometimes
you might get irrational but usually you
get irrational usually you'll get a
bigger space okay so this so just like
the rationals will complete to to to the
reals every space gets completed to to a
bigger space here so you know example
the natural numbers now live inside the
ultra power of the natural numbers so so
these guys are called a standard natural
numbers
these classical to non-standard
metronome bassoon yeah so among other
things out you pop out your products are
used to build non-standard analysis but
this is but it's it's not really a scary
time it's just noticed and once an
object is just basically an out show
them an ultra product of standard things
so for example the limit is the limit of
the sequence n 1 2 3 4 5 6 ok no that
doesn't exist in the classical sense or
you could say converts infinity or
something but this is so this is not a
standard natural number but it is a
non-standard natural number in this
bigger space okay and and in the REOs or
something live inside the the these are
the standard wheels these guys are the
non-standard resource called hyper
wheels and you can have things like the
limit goes from 1 to N 1 over N this is
not 0 because 0 and Norman disagree for
every N so the voters will see that one
of n is you are not the same space it
was caught in its a monastery was what's
called an infinitesimal we always like
you 0 but it's in contestant close to 0
it's a reciprocal this actual number
thank you
but ok which is an unbounded natural
number okay so you can put you can build
all these these these objects okay so so
already just from that you can just you
can formally take limits of everything
on the left and and get something which
is ministers which it's a so triviality
that yep you have a sequence for example
of grass a finite grass then just from
this ultra Prada construction I can I
can build for you and an internal graph
said listen so the Alpha is what it is
just the ultra product the ends and the
opposite is not a product of it ok so
I'm in this in this in this limiting
graph the vertices here are just ultra
limits of sequences of vertices in an
original graph and the and in any edge
use as a pair each pick each one of
which is an ultra limit alpha alpha but
it's a bit or pairs coming from the
original graph so ok so simple back you
can
take you can take logarithms of anything
okay
polymers variety or whatever but why
would you do this so the first
observation is that any operation that
you have on on the original discrete
objects carries over to the continuous
world and so suppose but some of you
have a group you give a secret of groups
so you've got an application operation
what's some an inversion operation this
is hesita application okay um a finite
group set okay so you can take a
sequence of finite groups and then you
can take click the ultra product okay so
yeah this guy this this is the set of
all formal limits of group elements one
from each repeating on you go said you
know you got maybe a want one group here
another group another group and it's a
much you take every single sequence and
you get the limiting point here and
it'll be this really huge uncountable
limit but the thing is it's it's still a
group least you've still got an
operation on it just like I want you to
find say addition on on the rationals
and then you completed you can define
addition of the real suspect because
additions continue a suspected to
cashier sequences like if you have two
elements in this limit group so what is
that so so one of them would be the
limit of one sequence coming from your
from your finite groups and then you got
another limit coming from another
sequence okay and you just you just
define the group law on this limiting
operation could when you do is it you
just go back to finite world you perform
the group application here and then to
cultural matters again and this is how
you how you define multiplication and
there's no issue or for convergence
because everything converges okay so
your business works yeah okay one thing
a check is is it set things up recover
it's like if you place the sequence of
your equivalent sequences work on the
sequence this product is two equivalent
but that just follows from the ultra
porter axioms okay so you can you can
define you can you can you can any
operation basically that already you
already had in the finite world still
I was still hold and also be there in
the in the limit and the great thing is
that is that any axiom that you really
had in the finite world will or likely
persist to to many more so the you know
the cuckoo is associative and if in a
firewall and it's very easy to see that
therefore in the limit the new post or
associative so the the ultra prodigal of
any secrets of groups is still a group
I'll just see prodigal fields to a field
I'll check on algebric closed fields the
Artic with the closed field and so on
and so forth in fact this is Chris is
great and called precocious theorem
alright what it basically says is that
is that if you have any predicate on
some finite number of variables and and
I knew also some constants and and these
will take values in some project space
so I guess going to index these things
okay so any predicate at all like likely
the associativity law or the inverse law
whatever using some constants and some
and some variables quantified over some
in some language using you know the form
that exists in everything quantified in
the space if this if this predicate is
true well now for large sort of n then
when you think outer limits of
everything can be if you take the or the
outer limit of all these variables these
variables and these constants and so
forth and now you're working in in the
optimal space then this thing we true
this the same predicate will be true in
the optimal space and conversely this if
it's true then this has to be true for
another large stead of it so never mind
exactly what this said but basically it
means that that anything you already
knew about in for four years no zipper
standard spaces are also true a little
bit so for example in the natural
numbers for math last theorems is a
theorem so automatically the complements
I seem is also true in the most kind of
natural numbers so you the e key then I
can tell you that there's no no instead
of normal bigger than two since the X to
the N plus y to the N
for some positive for some strictly
positive X Y Z where these are all
non-standard electrons it's also ultra
limits of nature and things like this
John bounded oh hey you know I know that
the senator natural must contain
infinite many pairs of primes 600 just
as a part the same thing is true okay -
- remembers hands on and so forth okay
so you don't really lose anything as
always just describable in first order
logic yeah of course for example you
know anything which is not described
what can be lost so if you like the way
all these good like well these because a
finite bit in a little bit you guys know
that's not finite but but being finite
it's not a first-order spread again okay
so you have these limits okay so maybe I
could give you an example of how you use
this machinery okay so I'll give you a
very simple example first and give you a
more advanced stick so I keep the talk
yesterday talking about the polynomial
regular than a start there
so this is a very simple thing but it
already illustrates some of the ideas
how you actually use these limits so
okay so let's let's test me out very
concrete let's take a field F which I
think was a finite field okay
and some some air some dimension D okay
no I didn't say okay let's call the
dimension capital N Pacific number okay
and let's define plumbers degree D F n
ok so these are just perennials
FN to F of degree so these two these are
called the quadratic polynomials on this
finite field vector space okay
F dozen have we finally should you can
declare as pilot okay so we have this
notion of rank so if you've upon omean
here you can define as we saw yesterday
the d minus one rank of P is the fewest
number yeah of degree D minus one
polynomials of degree less a lesson too
much one point on yours Q one Q M just
that P is a function so if you can write
your polynomial your deep degree
polynomial in terms of a finite number
of degree D minus one polynomials in
your finite rank and the smallest number
columns you need is the demand for mac
okay so we saw that before in a finite
field these lines are always finite in
an infinite fuel you can have fun in
Frank never mind okay so here let me
give you a simple case like you just the
first step of the polynomial regularity
lemma so okay so I haven't said a little
yet okay so what is the particle Emma's
it's the quantitative version which is
version if you use it okay so suppose
you have a bunch of polynomials e you're
so given any polynomials they may may
not have to have low rank of high rank
but okay so they have some polynomials
I'll senior function of Q function think
like an exponential italics vector
function so some rapidly going function
then I can always find a good basis I
can always find another set of
polynomials and these are the fewer of
these or this number Pisa is at most a
such that such that every pie where
every I oh yeah this and also a number M
and M is some bounded number bounded by
F okay there's the some number M but
only by this function f it's at our
exponential in f basically
such that for all four I ever epi
can be written as a linear combination
of three J's plus an error and this
error has valid rank the rank of these
errors so I can find a good basis of
polynomial such that the original
polynomials can be written as a linear
combination of these coefficients plus
an error of bounded rank and that these
guys are independent in the following
sense that there any there any
non-trivial combination so if you take
any non-trivial accommodation of obvious
coefficients of these polynomials and
these guys always a peptic rank and in
fact very big bigger than than the
function f applied to M so in fact this
using F is being like like a Tau
exponential so so these errors are
ranked at most M but the but these guys
have racked bigger than to the two to
the M or whatever so I'm really really
big yeah and so um okay this this this
is the okay the first step of the
problem we regularly lemma you in
practice you keep going you take upon me
what the D minus 1 degree problems like
that come up show up here and if you
recognize them further to D minus 2
polymers and so forth but let me just
ignore all the remaining steps of the
author process okay so this is a level
it's not hard to prove as we stated like
yesterday you know it's a very simple
algorithm you take these peas
polynomials and either either that
they're already sort of independent in
the sense that every every non-trivial
combination already has has really big
rank okay if they are independent like
that then you're ready done if not one
of them is equal is going to be written
as the combination of all the others
plus a bounder rank error so you remove
that polynomial reprint terms all the
way oh yeah and now you ask other guys
I'll let do all those independent and so
forth but you have to keep track of all
these quantitative things out what was
the rank of all the errors and so forth
and a little bit fiddley it's not
difficult but it's it's um
to actually write it down in full detail
the sister or it's a page but yeah you
have to you have to keep like this mm in
this F and it's little bit fiddly okay
on the other hand if you don't care
about bounce then it's really simple so
you see the quality version of the same
lemma very big leg so you know how a
field which can now can be infinite take
a bunch of polynomials in that viewable
yeah and now there's no function okay so
the claudette version is given a bunch
of polynomials I can find notice it upon
all be also with the fewer a subset
actually Ellucian and set such that
every polynomial is a linear combination
plus an error of or not just finite rank
okay okay so up to now finite micro
other than bounded rank there's a subtle
difference here okay that every program
accommodation of these polynomials and
this one is our independent modular
lower rank goes so
before and on show you so okay so the so
any combination these now now is
infinite rank right rather and then
bigger than this have ever okay now this
lever really is it the destemmer is just
an immediate consequence of all four of
second linear algebra C so a basic
theory in linear algebra is that if you
have a bunch of vectors in a vector
space then you can always find a sub
bases which are linear independent it
such that everybody here is a linear
combination of everybody here I mean
this doesn't this thing does name four
names associated so trivial it may be
every planet ever could be every him
every space every set of vectors has as
it has a linear independent basis okay
and this there are is you just apply
that that that lemma and to what what
you do is that you take the polynomials
of degree D and your quotient out by the
finite rank polynomials
see the great thing about working in the
qualitative world rather than quite
hittable is that the summer to fan it
make polynomials is still a fun track
and I saw the set of all fire is
polymers is a vector space and you can
quotient by it and this is something you
do in continuous mathematics quotients
you want to do this in the discrete
world it would make this little or just
make it a lot easier if you could
quotient by all bounded rank objects but
you can't quite because it's not by
cosine audition but somewhere to things
rank M is ranked to M and so you don't
have a single space or Bannerman objects
you just absolutely so this whole nested
sort of family of spaces but in the
closet word you have won the the the
finite monomials and so you just take
the original polynomials quotient up by
finite rank this is in a vector space
linear who tells you there's a basis
there pull it back and it gives you the
skill okay so you you're not to work
okay you have to work you have to use a
very trivial linear algebra fact now
okay so alright now this seam looks
weaker than this stuff of course if you
have a quantitative lemma then it's very
easy to deduce the rivet never but these
are key equivalent okay once you have
the quality of regularity lemma you just
use an ultra product and you ordering
together I think that the binary thing
take so let me see if I can do that
pshh okay this was supposed to be one of
several examples I get but I have one
okay
I was going to show you that if they do
a 70 record a demo and the ultra product
method that was probably the most
interesting this because this is very
simple for this four syllable or warmup
okay so suppose you know the qualitative
regularity lemma why is the quantity of
regularity of that mark true okay so
y'all got a contradiction okay so
suppose quantitative limits false okay
so then you go negate all these
quantifiers so yeah it's a bit messy bit
but it what you find is it is eg when
you carefully get everything or you find
is fine
this means that that there is no bound I
had that this time is not true for for
any bound on am so okay so that they
exist a function such that no matter how
large your bound you pick you can find a
field F N and mention guess and then
okay okay you can find a few old you can
find a dimension you can find a set of
polynomials looks suit okay so that then
you find it a set of polynomials
in in this vector space such that such
that you can't do this okay so said for
know okay um yeah okay this is this this
looks complicated but it's it's very
straightforward that once you get a
practice with this it is always alright
just hold your nose and it also always
work out but okay but yeah the first
time to do it s be rather careful so you
can find a bunch of columns just that no
matter what can you pick up to the
specified range there is no u1 up to QB
a such that these things are true okay
okay I'll just call this white okay so
when you can negate this yeah you negate
this this this statement you get a
rather complicated assertion but okay
you get something so basically but the
general students philosophy says you
take a quadrant save it negate it then
once you once you have this counter
example you take the ultra protocol a
counter example and that will give you a
counter example to it to this lemma here
so maybe I won't do it but okay so you
so here the sequence of fields you take
it out repair a geek another fuel okay
you take this out yeah and you take out
on these vector spaces you get you get a
big vector space over this business
field you take the entrepreneur these
polynomials of degree D you get another
problem of degree D over this much
bigger vector space and okay movie I
won't do it but I'll just you can just
delete me that that if you take the
ultra product of everything in that I
des rois we're done here you'll get a
counter example to statement here and
hence because this is true this has to
be true as well
okay so um
okay so it's still the same proof you
know here you're you know the how do you
how do you prove this lemma that every
that every five acres has it has an
independent basis you run the same
algorithm that you do to do the whole
thing like that if they're independently
you're done otherwise one them is in
some of the others and so forth
but the thing is this is already another
literature right you don't actually have
to to to use this to explain argument
again you can just use as a black box
and you know yeah these convenient thing
you take quotients and so forth I mean
so it's repackaging the same argument
but in s of a clean conceptual way
you're not to worry about exactly what
low rank and big rank mean and this is
it's all done automatically for you okay
I won't have time to regularity lemma
unfortunately I think I can do the
correspondence principle okay maybe I'll
just end of that okay so um
somebody's theorem okay so what's uh
okay somebody's there Matt Fraser like
this that's awful for for every K and
every don't hurt that exist an N such
that for all subsets walls mission large
end project oh yes such that there's a
subset that that every source of images
I want to end of density at least Delta
n the cajon anti progression okay so
this this is somebody's theorem so
Firstenberg
proof is theorem by proving a measure
theoretic analog so for every K and
every major preserving system excellent
emerge opposing system is is it ism
it's a probability space with a shift
which preserves measure so if you have
any any space X with a with a measure
probability measure maybe shift on it
and any set of positive measure now so
there's no don't anymore just positivity
this is more qualitative statement then
you can find a positive number n such
that a inch the shift of a and the shift
away it's more times also as positive
measure okay so given any set a it's
possible to shift it get them again so
that the intersection is system all
empty ISOs positive measure in
particulars non-empty okay so this is a
thing that you can prove by I got a few
methods but you don't need to know how
it's proven if you wouldn't accept as a
black box this theme again is sucky
equivalent to summaries theorem if you
have summary scoop it's easy to
this theorem you're going to look at a
typical orbit of a point and that took
orbit it would be like a dense set as
I'm ready but conversely you can use
this qualitative results to prove this
cook this quantity over though and the
way you do this is that okay so if this
is suppose not so suppose my assume is
false then then after because it exists
a K and a delta and a sequence of n will
be a sequence of numbers going to parity
and a sequence of a n inside these these
it was n n of all of positive density
such that no way in Connecticut KB so
you've got a sequence of counter
examples which are getting bigger and
bigger
okay but we all have uniform or density
and it's possible to take a node ultra
prototype of everything so these ends
will do you take you take an ultra
product and you'll get a non-standard
natural number so those are not natural
numbers then you'll is much bigger sort
of double position natural numbers if
you wish okay long natural numbers okay
all right and okay you take an old Chile
man so you get this really big
non-standard after nationalize which is
bigger than all the standard ones and
you get a subset of okay so yeah this is
this big interval now n equals this this
big subset here eight now each of these
finite intervals here comes to a natural
measure which is the normalized counting
measure so on these NS there's a reason
there's a natural measure which is just
that the density measure the list
probably measure on this space there's a
way to the ultra protocol measures how
you have a bit careful because
measure theory is not a first order
theory and you have to use the
categories Yeti is a curable measure
theory to do this but okay but it is
possible to construct a measure a
probably measure on this space which in
some sense is the ultra limit of the
optimization I won't explain how that
works occurs at all time
but it's called load measure look it up
okay so there's a nice probability
measure on here which is in some sense
the ultra product of other measures here
and so all this as a positive density if
you take the limit you get a set and it
will still a positive in City so we
measure pigment evidence turns out now
why do you pass this limit the thing is
over here the limit you have a shift X
goes to X plus 1 which isn't quite well
yeah and then you wrap around if you go
over here you refer to zero and the
thing is or actually or okay well I can
only need to find almost everywhere okay
so you don't define at the end points
but the end points have much to zero
once you it so outside this emerges 0
this the ship dismiss water fight and
and this is a much observing system you
see on any on any finite interval the
shift is not measure observing because
every time you should buy one more
somebody falls off the edge okay and so
you lose a little bit measure but but
uni in the infinite world well once you
go to this this noise done or you up to
such measure 0 you are you are invariant
and and fürstenberg still can tolerate
bosses as much as zero and so you've now
constructed a much observing system and
this cut this it's not hard to show that
this sequence of current examples in
limit gives you a seeker example to so
what you see is that every time you move
a quantitative about about finally
things you assume it fails you have a
sequence count examples take an ultra
product and this would be count example
to some continuous statement and you
just prove that continual statement then
you prove no to a discrete thing and you
can do this for all kinds of other
things like the regular glimmer and so
forth but that I think up well you
intercept until you in person
I have no idea - it sounds a little bit
I mean it's very old topic and I mean
your Baba to use them all the time but
they were the first of me Thomas
actually I'm one of the people who
originally designed our products in late
fifties when an influencer party I
didn't understand the river of time
because allotted in terms of boolean
algebra that later we define dr. college
so I was the first person to prove the
compactive soon what happened would you
use it
yeah it's implicitly I didn't talk about
those a little weird after 55 years to
hear a lecture about what recovers I'm
glad you're bringing the back movie
please consciousness because there lot
of head around uses of them and approach
the work of Jerry Keesler in this
robbery is very very important you refer
to the word measure that that's a
special case indecent is such an amazing
discovery and so I hope people will find
all the occupations oh yeah yeah let's
test this and it's over diesel stuff so
this was done schools okay all right
okay yes constructive um it heck it is
yes it is literally constructive okay so
in the sense that the way it works is
that time you work in a universe of the
immerseus in which you went into the
oven and on CFC and then inside the
university can do is go to construct
constructible universe
roughly speaking this that's all the
things that you can define uniquely with
predicates and even if your external
universe doesn't have a choice then the
in this this new sub university
constructor does not have a choice I
think it's I think it's like a [ __ ]
universe
see the vol chemicals much okay even
better than properties it sure feels
absolutely yes that's true I don't know
yeah I don't I don't know how that one's
people know that that's more difficult
period yeah well yeah so this is sub
universe which you have choice so new PC
and and it turns out that the natural
numbers are the same in both universes
and so whatever you improve in picking
best-looking this is so so when you
introduce a planetary Darren's been from
me from the implant so you don't get any
effect two realms if you if you use the
infinitive as a black box that you get
absolutely no down whatsoever
in practice though II if you actually
hope in the black box and you look at at
every single step in the proof of
leaflet and then then usually every
single step in the infinite world has
some analog in the fire but not really
much messier a lot more epsilon two
qualifiers and every time you can take a
limit yet instead run an algorithm and
this is lot more looping and but so you
can unpack and so roughly speaking you
know if you can prove the Internet's
able you know using a proof of some
complexity and then you can get a bow
which is which is somehow like you know
a tower or high command or something
there's this there's some relation
between the difficulty of the proof of
the infinite statement and the and the
balance that show up but typical things
at how exponential I
the whole of whom I have is that if
you're probably finding yourself and the
only bounds that you hope to get anyway
italics potential then you may as well
go to the infinite world because you're
not losing much by piling up a bit but
if there's charge Apollo me about and so
forth then it's this usually you don't
want to use in order to prove that one
yes I see the fact that you generally
get the power of Exponential's and it's
just it's just kind of an empirical demo
or it was a general there are these
general this isn't called proof mining
that the proof yourself to I don't know
the precise statements that these are
but rath is how many times you have to
do things like take limits takes pans or
tech completions see you somewhere here
in the in the polling regularity example
we are I died
oh you yeah often well you what you do
in cleanest voice so if you have a
finite number generators or some smalls
are generating you just look at what all
this in your in a span but you look at
it you leave all the combinations and
you take a completion every time you I
could use one of one of those
completions that cost that will cost you
some time when you go back to the finite
world I mean it's something that you do
or that forms a lot of thinking you just
you know take span see completions and
clears well know that that is an
alternative work was expensive
do we have any notion of rate for the
ultra limit would it be meaningful to
have such a notion
well I mean you can use very severe
fantasmas to adjudicate rate so like if
you have a sequence of numbers that
converge to zero classically in the
classical sense then you take the ultra
limit then the ultimate is not zero it's
what's going from decimal but this this
different ranges we have a decimal so
example I can let epsilon be the limit
of one over N okay so this is an example
of infinitesimal this interessant will
be less than Epsilon
if xn is eventually less than 1 over m
if it's that's a lot of info an alpha
backside of it then business lesson okay
but so for example is equals over N
squared is less than Epsilon
but you can you can ask you can ask are
you lessen or squared which is a faster
rate or either are you I are you less
than e to minus 1 of Epsilon that's an
even faster right so so rates of
convergence become replaced by Mike just
comparison versus Vanessa moss so so
when you go to the North underworld you
don't see limits anymore because somehow
or limbs have already been taken what I
ought to know is it takes all your
elements for your wants to the beginning
and then topless and analysis becomes
algebra yeah
and saying that one sequence is
eventually bigger than others just
saying that that one is less than a
constant as the other we
thanks Harry